je suis parti des mecs qui ont pris
vraiment le plus plein la tronche
c'est-à-dire que bah oui j'ai un tout
petit camarades dans des carrières assez
flat moi ça a été des succès des échecs
des succès des échecs je me suis pris
plein de galets qui plein de gamelles
moi j'ai eu des patrons qui m'ont dit tu
vois bien que les gens veulent plus te
voir tu vas mettre le public tu veux
plus donc mets-toi au vert c'est bon
faut voir les épaules quand même parce
que moi c'est un métier que j'aime en
vrai sinon je serai pas là
alors malheureusement on n'a pas
Castaldi parce que quand tu dévisses
moi je le comprends parce qu'il a été
tellement au sommet après les moments où
il n'est plus rien c'est invivable nous
qui ne sommes pas je me compare pas du
tout mais tu ne sonne pas grand chose
mais toi toi mais voilà mais quand par
exemple il y a un moment où moi vous
m'appeliez plus pour l'émission et
encore une fois c'est totalement
légitime jamais je vous ai demandé
pourquoi quand on est quand on est à la
moi ça a duré deux mois et demi c'est
vrai qu'à ce moment là on se dit est-ce
que je vais revenir est-ce qu'il faut
que je me réoriente etc donc ça nous
fait poser des questions on est seul
chez soi on travaille pas donc moi je
suis quasiment à plein temps chez vous
quand je bosse donc ça nous fait
réfléchir lui c'est exponentiel donc je
comprends je comprends que ce soit dur à
vivre voilà
un peu plus calme on peut aussi on peut
aussi voir et c'est très important aussi
de comprendre que les gens qui sont des
personnes des publics ne doivent pas
flamber en proportion de ce qui gagne à
l'instant T et c'est important d'avoir
les pieds sur terre
dans le cul à son patron
remercier il était spectateurs parce que
c'est vrai que je voulais vous dire
merci parce qu'on se rendait compte de
ça avec la chaîne la dernière fois je
crois que on va pouvoir communiquer
là-dessus je crois que je suis
l'animateur qui est resté le plus
longtemps en direct sur une quotidienne
si longtemps donc merci les chéris parce
que c'est vrai qu'on voit que c'est
tellement comme ça que c'est incroyable
et merci à vous d'être aussi fidèle
parce que ça ça me touche vraiment et
c'est vrai que 12 ans de quotidienne je
crois que c'est jamais arrivé donc
merci et je vous dis
et merci à la bande aussi non mais c'est
vrai parce que c'est une bombe un TP les
gens me disent vous êtes mes jambes
disons j'aime bien la bande j'aime bien
la famille que vous avez mais c'est vrai
oui Delphine tu parles de l'argent mais
dans ce cas-là il parle pas vraiment de
l'argent on parle plus du désir du désir
qui pouvait procurer chez les directeurs
de chaîne et moi je trouve que c'est
quand même dur parce qu'effectivement du
jour au lendemain comme tu dépends du
désir des autres quand tu es un
animateur et ben en fait on dit on veut
plus ta tronche en fait c'est de l'ego
en fait c'est un métier d'égo et c'est
pour ça que c'est important de se poser
et d'être un peu dans la sagesse
c'est pas que ça non plus parce que la
France 2 quand ils écart Patrick
Sébastien parce que c'est un mâle de
plus de 50 ans blanc et qu'on en veut
plus l'important ça marche pourtant ça
fonctionne pourtant il fait de
l'audience et on lui dit mais monsieur
on veut plus de vous parce que vous êtes
trop vieux parce qu'on veut on veut
rajeunir on veut mettre des femmes à
l'antenne donc pardon je trouve que ça
peut être très très violent
Patrick Sébastien il a 60 ans quand
c'est arrivé pour lui tout ça il en
avait à peu près 40 non plus que ça 45
si tu veux je suis un très bien il avait
quel âge il a 63 ans il avait 50 bon
donc
tu es au top du du sommet pardon on va
dire la vérité karma en général les
animateurs reviennent le weekend bien
les animateurs qui ne reviennent pas en
général à l'antenne sont ceux qui
lorsqu'ils étaient au top pardon mais il
faut dire la vérité était audio
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que tu as
je suis désolé je n'ai rien contre lui
il a bossé avec bocolini ça s'est mal
passé avec des victoires c'est mal passé
avec tout le monde moi je l'ai connu
aussi ça c'est mal passé il a bossé avec
tous Jean-Michel la connu ça s'est mal
passé mais il est odieux
pardon sa traversée du désert et c'est
vrai que Dieu Géraldine t'as raison le
problème d'égo c'est important quand tu
peux pas remplir ton frigo c'est plus
important et quand il était dans sa
traversée du désert j'étais un grand
prix de Formule 1 j'étais invité comme
aujourd'hui j'étais au Figaro il
arrivait en hélico il m'a pris dans sa
voiture il voulait un sponsor pour la
faire la coupe Porsche il y a des
problèmes plus important dans la vie que
que de pas trop de sponsors
on te tend la main quand à quand tu es
dans le Quand tu es dans le trou mais tu
t'es bien avec les gens personne n'a
attendu la main une scène aucun
producteur pourquoi mais parce que ce
mec est audio après moi je le dis moi
c'est vrai que au départ on s'entendait
pas de fou maintenant s'entend très bien
et le plus drôle et c'est vrai que moi
je l'aime bien à chaque fois qu'il vient
on se marre bien voilà ça se passe bien
la guerre j'ai produit sur sur C8 ça
s'est bien passé regarde ce que tu as
des excès d'un amour elle le dit
gentiment que ces mots le plus compliqué
à gérer c'était de Chavanne
complications
qu'il a fait que boccolinise par les
mêmes pas il s'insultaient
avec Christophe et très bien passé TF1
non ça s'est mal passé
en fait au début exactement parce que la
première émission c'est pas bien passée
donc on s'en est parlé et il a très
enfin on s'est dit les choses à un
moment avec Christophe en fait il faut
dire les choses
quand il est venu ici sur ce plateau ici
il a dit bonjour au revoir à personne
par contre c'est juste un film c'est pas
vrai
il est hyper stressé il est compliqué
mais c'est quelqu'un qui a donné sa
chance c'est quelqu'un qui a créé plein
d'émissions c'est quelqu'un
laissez-moi finir c'est quelqu'un qui
moi j'ai toujours dit en relation pas
finir Jean-Mi j'ai toujours parlé avec
lui parfois ça a été compliqué mais
c'est quelqu'un qui a oui un affect et
c'est quelqu'un c'est vrai que c'est
pour arrêter de dire beaucoup compliqué
quand la personne a un sale caractère
c'est trop facile
franchement il est moi je croyais pas
qu'il était aussi stressé c'est-à-dire
que c'est un mec qui est vraiment il est
hyper stressé il est hyper non mais il
est hyper pointilleux il se prend la
tête
quand je l'ai produis sur apprendre à
laisser moi je vous dis la vérité moi
j'arrivais bon franchement je t'ai pas
stressé ou trop mesures par l'émission
et par les règles je dirais je me on
verra bien là-bas un petit peu voilà on
verra sur place et puis on verra et
c'est avec Christophe il regardait les
règles il m'a dit alors ça je fais ça je
vais essayer stressé c'est il est voilà
et on les gens prennent parfois sont
stress pour de
l'antipathie
vous allez voir si c'est du stress je
termine on était sur circuit de Formule
1 à Magny-Cours on devait faire trois
tours il pensait que j'avais trouvé que
j'étais au patron des services médias
vous m'avez connu à ce point-là Figaro
et vous pensez que j'allais trouver un
sponsor pour la Porsche pour se faire la
compétition de Porsche il dit on part
pour trois tours ça va Jean-Michel on
part on truc comme ça et dans le premier
tour il s'aperçoit que en fait j'ai pas
du tout le bras Londres jamais eu trop
euh sponsor on termine le premier tour
il rentre dans l'Espagne ouvre la porte
il me dit même pas au revoir il me dit
montrer comme ça sort de la voiture il
est reparti
c'est du stress certainement dû péter
leur prisme en fait c'est votre ego qui
vous fait parler comme ça
je voyais une pendule arriver avec une
table qui bougeait un éléphant un
dromadaire du public
éclater les scores
les gens les gens ils aimaient
Christophe dechavan comment il a dévissé
lui jamais personne autour de la table
va dévisser comme lui il y a trois mecs
il y a deux il y a il y avait Drucker
après lui il est arrivé il a inventé une
télé en direct ensuite derrière tu avais
Cauet qui a inventé les mornings et car
inventé de la télé avec la Méthode Cauet
et le troisième c'est lui le troisième
rapport c'est quoi aucune chaîne ne l'a
rappelé avec les parce qu'il est au dieu
traverser le désert pourquoi la
traversée qu'il a eu que toi tu auras
jamais que personne n'aura jamais parce
qu'il est monté tellement haut pas du
tout mais pas du tout comme Cauet qui
est monté tellement haut comme lui qui
est tellement haut que quand il va
s'arrêter tout le monde va tout le monde
va dire que c'est un génie tout le monde
va dire que c'est un génie parce que
pourquoi tu le fais ça aujourd'hui là ne
chroniqueur le direct peut-être que tu
le fais parce que Dechavannes a ouvert
une
TuneIn Quand tu es dans le trou ça veut
dire que quand tu étais en haut tu te
comportes
mon expérience perso moi je dis la
vérité hier soir j'étais dans le trou
personne à ton avis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais oublier que les gens qu'on croise
en montant sont les mêmes qu'on recroise
en redescendre Jean-Marie je te vois
exemple en vrai Jean-Marie tata qui est
plus populaire de France ça même si ce
n'est voilà si tu fais partie des trois
quatre
des plus gros humoristes de France et
dans le top 3 pour toujours bien sûr et
tu as quand même fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de plateaux télé tu as
travaillé avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'animateurs dis la vérité quels sont
ceux qui sont le plus impressionnés qui
tournent le plus fait marrer qui ont été
le plus
voilà le plus désagréable le plus
désagréable quand justement
il y a Michel Drucker
en réalisateur il y a Claude Lelouch tu
vois imparable un crevable tu vois et
puis sinon les gens qui tournent le dos
ils le font d'une manière
que toi ils tournent le dos sans se
faire trop voir et puis tu te retrouves
tout seul comme un con après je vais te
dire un truc il y a aussi des gens qui
tournent le dos je te dis tout mon
Jean-Marie c'est que c'est comme je
t'aime c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de mecs
aussi qui ont peur pour leur place et
qui se disent moi je peux pas prendre le
risque de rappeler Jean-Marie qui ont
pas mine de rien mais c'est vrai il y a
plein de mecs aussi comme ça qui se
disent moi j'ai pas envie de me mettre
des délais des difficultés Jean-Marie
parfois il a pu faire polémique sur deux
trois petites choses
sur la photo avec toi et ça c'était
c'est une solitude incroyable et tu vois
la phrase qu'il avait sorti dans une
interview aussi parce qu'évidemment on
sait jamais de sa faute de Chabanne il
avait sorti aujourd'hui quand tu as 60
ans que tu es blanc et hétérosexuel tu
ne peux plus faire de télévision
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire cette phrase Jean-Marie
juste et c'est même pas me dire une
méchanceté
non mais c'est vrai que tu as travaillé
Christophe toi ça a toujours bien passé
et que je t'ai vu faire plein de trucs
mais c'était très occasionnel souvent
c'était moi qui avait écrit le truc fait
deux trois petits sketchs ensemble et ça
c'est très bien passé je n'ai pas eu à
mon plaindre j'ai pas suffisamment
pratiqué Christian c'était le ton
moi j'allais le voir
changement de programme sur deux
Chavanne
Cyril Hanouna n'a pas l'air de savoir
que dechavan liker les commentaires
contre lui il y a quelques mois alors
que Hanouna est plein d'éloges pour lui
alors c'est une merde
[Applaudissements]
quand même un peu mais moi il y a une
histoire de fou et Christophe Dechavanne
un jour Christophe Dechavanne je suis je
suis le matin et je sais plus je vois
qu'il m'a encore défoncé dans une
interview donc là je l'appelle gentiment
allô ouais il me dit c'est qui je dis
Cyril Hanouna je lui dis tu es où là il
me dit je suis dans l'avion
tu rentres quand il dit je rentre demain
je lui dis demain tu es à droite
je vais te ta race donc je lui
dis le lendemain je vais à Europe 1 et
donc on s'est parlé et
toi
je parle pas au téléphone je dis pas
dans les raisons je parle pas pareil
interview voilà fini on va se voir tous
les deux on va se parler voilà on s'est
parlé depuis un mot sur moi tu prône que
Clara il a dit pas de problème je me
taire depuis sais-tu non c'était plutôt
bien passé
ce que je disais tout à l'heure avec
Christophe en fait il faut pas prendre
sur soi il faut lui dire là j'ai été
malheureuse et quand aussi Christophe
j'étais malheureux que tu commences à
dire un peu la vérité toujours dans le
coffre d'une voiture on comprend
j'étais malheureux
non je l'adore maintenant c'est un super
pote non mais faut arrêter de le
retrouver des excuses à ces animateurs
en disant ils sont stressés ils sont
anxieux déjà non mais il y a plein de
gens il y a plein d'animateurs qui sont
extrêmement sympathiques à l'antenne et
qui dès que les caméras sont coupées
sont odieux avec les gens avec entre
guillemets ceux qui considèrent avec des
petites gens avec les autres alors j'ai
un grand animal j'ai un grand
journaliste
l'animateur le seul qui a insulté menacé
les journalistes moi le premier voilà
non mais si tu veux si tu veux on peut
alors moi
je dis la vérité moi j'ai toute la
vérité
dans la vie quand les gens viennent vous
voir vous êtes toujours sympa vous êtes
sympa avec les équipes c'est vrai et
c'est une réalité il y a des animateurs
qui sont détestables qui sont
antipathiques et qui quand à leurs yeux
vous n'êtes pas important vous traite
comme de la merde c'est ce qui lui est
arrivé donc quand il se plaint bah c'est
juste que pendant 10 ans il était audio
avec tous les patrons de chaîne avec
tout le monde à TF1 avec tout le monde
et bah du coup vous êtes dur vous êtes
mais quand on regarde dans quel état
fantastique
vous vous osez retendre la des gens qui
ont pu bosser depuis longtemps et même
le qu'en dira-t-on vous en foutez et
vous remettez vous remettez beaucoup de
personnes
tout simplement est-ce qu'on vous a dit
attention jamais et il faudrait
peut-être pas
alors on aurait pu lui dire monsieur
ici on a une liberté incroyable et merci
d'ailleurs au patron de la chaîne
vraiment parce qu'on est une liberté
incroyable et Jean-Marie j'ai eu un
flash
un loin j'ai dit tiens j'ai failli
attendre
aussi pris des gens au top moi à
l'époque j'étais au top NRJ12 non mais
on n'a pas pris de voilà allez allez
allez